[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
herzlich Willkommen zu Tatort
Deutschland eurem täglichen truecrime
Podcast mein Name ist Mirko Kasimir und
ich bin Toni Heyer hallo heute nehmen
wir euch mit in das Jahr 1989 und nach
Beverly Hills die vielleicht oder die
berühmteste Nachbarschaft der Welt das
Kino Revier des Beverly Hills Cop
Postleitzahl
90210 Heimat von Stars und Sternchen
also eigentlich die perfekte Traumwelt
der Anfang dieser Geschichte der könnte
auch aus einem Prospekt für den American
Dream stammen aber ihr kennt uns sie
wird sich in einen Albtraum verwandeln
und sie wirft Fragen auf die bis heute
nicht gelöst sind und die weit über den
Fall den besonderen Ort und die damalige
Zeit hinausreichen Mirko los geht's
die Villa der Familie minnes am Drive
liegt nur wenige Blocks vom protzigen
Rodeo Drive entfernt einer der
bekanntesten und teuersten Straßen der
Welt und Kulisse in zahlreichen
Hollywood-Filmen es ist eine Gegend in
der es einfacher ist schnell mal eine
Rolex oder einen Porsche zu kaufen als
einen Sack Kartoffeln oder Klopapier was
für die Leute die hier wohnen natürlich
kein Problem ist da sich um so etwas in
der Regel das Personal kümmert
die Villa ist in spanischem Stil
gehalten 5 Millionen Dollar hat Vater
Russe mennendes dafür hingeblättert das
entspricht heute etwa 12 Millionen
Dollar
vor der Familie haben hier schon Elton
John und Michael Jackson gewohnt
Rosés hat es geschafft so viel steht
fest
wird 1944 in Kuba geboren mit 16 also
nach der kubanischen Castro Revolution
da emigrierte in die Vereinigten Staaten
erlebt anfangs bei Verwandten in
Pennsylvania und er jobt unter anderem
buchstäblich als Tellerwäscher also so
wirklich der amerikanische Traum José
ist Leistungssportler erst Schwimmer und
erhält dadurch bald ein College
Stipendium in illinoise dort lernt der
Mary Louis Anderson kennen genannt Kitty
eine Schönheitskönigin
1963 heiraten die beiden
1968 wird Sohn Joseph lael geboren
1970 sein Bruder Eric gailen
und José macht Karriere er wird Manager
bei der Autovermietung Herz und wechselt
schließlich in die Unterhaltungsbranche
Anfang der 80er Jahre ist er ein hohes
Tier bei der Plattenfirma arce Records
unter anderem bringt er die Deals mit
Duran Duran und den Eurythmics unter
Dach und Fach schließlich wechselt er
ins Film Business arbeitet unter anderem
mit Sylvester Stallone zusammen und
zieht mit der Familie nach Beverly Hills
die Söhne Eric und leil werden in ihrer
Jugend zu erfolgreichen Tennisspielern
leil zählt sogar zu den besten seiner
Altersklasse eine Vorzeigefamilie und
dann
am Abend des 20 August 1989 erschießen
leil und Eric ihren Vater und ihre
Mutter aus nächster Nähe mit insgesamt
16 Schüssen aus zwei Schrotflinten
ich denke wir müssen da wohl doch noch
mal hinter diese Fassade der
Vorzeigefamilie schauen aber bevor wir
das machen gib uns doch noch mal ein
bisschen mehr Details zu diesem Abend zu
diesem schrecklichen Mord wie ist das
abgelaufen okay ich beginne erstmal mit
der Version die die beiden Brüder der
Polizei präsentiert haben
danach hat die ganze Familie den Tag wie
so oft auf dem Tennisplatz verbracht
abends gehen Erik und leil ins Kino sie
wollen sich Batman von Tim Burton
anschauen den Mega Blockbuster des
Jahres 1989
danach wollen sie essen gehen und sich
später mit einem Freund treffen und ein
paar Bier trinken eric ist da erst 18
Jahre zu jung um mit den USA Alkohol zu
kaufen doch er hat einen gefälschten
Ausweis den er dummerweise zu Hause
vergessen hat
also fahren Sie nach Hause um den
Ausweis zu holen und finden ihre Eltern
tot
schrecklich zugerichtet durch Schüsse
aus großkalibringen Waffen
ein Detail fällt ihnen trotz des Schocks
sofort auf die Knie des Vaters sind
zerschossen für die beiden ein Hinweis
auf einen mafia-mord im Internet
kursiert eine Aufzeichnung ihres
nine-one Notrufes sie haben meine Eltern
erschossen ruft
als die Polizei eintrifft finden Sie die
beiden Brüder in Verzweiflung Erik liegt
zusammengerollt auf dem Rasen und weinte
sterisch die Brüder werden vernommen
mehrere Stunden lang aber als
traumatisierte Zeugen des Mordes nicht
als Verdächtiger
kann ich voll verstehen zumal ist zu dem
Zeitpunkt wahrscheinlich auch noch gar
keine Indizien gibt dass die beiden ihre
Eltern umgebracht haben also klar viele
Verbrechen finden im engsten
Familienkreis statt zum Beispiel oft
sind das Ehemänner die ihre Frauen töten
aber das Kinder ihre eigenen Eltern
töten das will man auch im ersten Moment
gar nicht denken ja und erst recht nicht
wenn man direkt mit ihrer
offensichtlichen Verzweiflung
konfrontiert ist
im Nachhinein sieht man was da falsch
lief zum Beispiel wurden ihre Finger
nicht auf Schmauchspuren untersucht
hätte man das getan wäre ihre Geschichte
sehr schnell als Lüge entlarvt worden so
aber geht die Polizei von Mafia morgen
aus genau wie die Brüder es gehofft
hatten
die beiden Brüder nennen sogar einen
Namen um die Ermittlungen in die falsche
Richtung zu lenken Noel blue ein Rivale
ihres Vaters der könnte hinter den
Morden stecken ihr Glück denn die
Polizei hat kaum weitere Anhaltspunkte
die Tatwaffen sind nicht auffindbar und
die Täter haben sich sogar die Mühe
gemacht sämtliche Geschosshülsen
zusammenzusammeln und verschwinden zu
lassen ja sie waren offenbar sehr
gründlich und professionell
Fingerabdrücke der Täter finden die
Ermittler auch nicht glauben sie
zumindest klar da sind überall jede
Menge Fingerabdrücke der Opfer und ihrer
beiden Söhne im Haus aber die gehören da
schließlich hin und so kommen die beiden
Brüder mit ihrer Geschichte durch
vorerst denn schon bald beginnen sich
Freunde Bekannte und die Polizei über
das Verhalten der beiden zu wundern sie
geben das Geld ihres ermordeten Vaters
mit vollen Händen aus vor allem Leihe
der ältere Bruder verfällt in einen
regelrechten Shoppingrausch mehrere
tausend Dollar gehen für neue Klamotten
drauf er lässt sich in einer Limousine
samt Bodyguard herumkutieren er kauft
sich ein Porsche Carrera und ein Café in
Princeton und als ob so ein Porsche
nicht so teuer genug wäre setzt er noch
einen drauf und kauft nicht irgendein
sondern klar die teures Special Edition
und er heuert auch noch ein tenniscoach
an der ihn jeden Tag 10 Stunden zur
Verfügung steht
solche Kleinigkeiten wie Rolex Uhren die
lassen wir mal außen vor live versucht
ebenfalls in die Fußstapfen seines
Vaters zu treten und ein erfolgreicher
Geschäftsmann zu werden er investiert in
diverse Firmen die man heute wohl
Start-up nennen würde so wirklich
erfolgreich ist aber nicht das liegt vor
allem daran weil er praktisch ohne jede
Erfahrung ist und sein Geld vor allem in
die Business und Schnapsideen von
Freunden steckt in den ersten Monaten
nach dem Tod ihrer Eltern geben Laila
und Eric ca eine Millionen Dollar aus
man könnte böse sagen nicht die
gängigste Art zu trauern ja vollkommen
richtig mit der Trauer der beiden da
scheint es nicht besonders weit hier zu
sein ganz im Gegenteil sie genießen ihr
neues Leben als reiche Erben einem
Freund der sich über ihr Verhalten
wundert erklärt leil
ich habe so lange darauf gewartet in
einer solchen Position zu sein dass der
Übergang einfach war obwohl das viele
verwundert wird das doch etwas
verständlicher als bekannt wird dass das
Leben der Familie millennendes
keineswegs idyllisch war sondern dass
die Villa in Beverly Hills den Söhnen
oft wie im Gefängnis vorgekommen sein
muss Rossi männerdes war ein äußerst
strenger und ehrgeiziger Vater die
Tenniskarriere seiner Söhne ist vor
allem Sein Wille er pusht die beiden
gnadenlos demütigt sie bei Misserfolgen
in der Öffentlichkeit oft ist er beim
Training selbst vor Ort und mischt sich
ein
damit und mit der Härte gegenüber seinen
Kindern vergrault er sogar Tennislehrer
die immerhin so einiges gewohnt sind von
über ambitionierten Eltern vor allem
eric hat zu leiden immer wieder
bezeichnet der Vater ihn als Schwächling
verhöhnt ihn vor anderen und vor seinem
älteren Bruder und die Mutter Kitty die
schaut zu den beiden Jungs mangelt es
eigentlich ja nichts außer an Liebe
die Geschichte wird noch viel düsterer
Werbung du Marius ja ich liebe ja die
TV-Serie Julia Leischik sucht bitte
melde dich die schaue ich ja am liebsten
mit meiner Mama zusammen denn in dieser
Serie geht es darum dass die Julia quasi
um die halbe Welt fliegt um vermisste
Menschen zu suchen und Familien die
lange Zeit voneinander getrennt waren
die wieder zusammenzuführen und das
macht sie jetzt schon seit sage und
schreibe 18 Jahren und ich kann dir eins
sagen bei uns auf der Couch daheim
bleibt kein Auge trocken das kann ich
mir sehr gut vorstellen aber Rakel weißt
du was ich erzähle dir jetzt mal was es
gibt das ganze nämlich jetzt auch zum
Hören im brandneuen Podcast julia
Leischik spurlos echt jetzt erzähl mir
mehr ja jede Woche gibt es einen neuen
rätselhaften und emotionalen Fall ne wie
du das kennst Julia erzählt das zusammen
im Podcast aber mit ihrem langjährigen
Kollegen Michael Strasser und ich finde
hört man sofort das ist eine
eingefrorenes Team oder die beiden die
sind schon seit so vielen Jahren da
zusammen unterwegs fürs Fernsehen reisen
um die ganze Welt um diese Vermissten zu
suchen da hörst du einfach dass es
natürlich auch Freunde geworden sind
aber nicht nur die beiden kommen zu Wort
sondern auch direkt betroffene
Angehörige Kriminalbeamte Experten und
die schildern dann alle ihre Sicht auf
den Fall also liefern sie quasi einen
Blick hinter die Kulissen genau ja also
man kann sagen das ist so eine True
Crime wie sie da den Fällen nachgehen
trifft auf große Emotionen wie easy
liebt da zu Hause auf der Couch der
Podcast julia Leischik spurlos jeden
Mittwoch gibt es eine neue Folge also
hört auf jeden Fall rein und um keine
Folge zu verpassen abonniere die julia
Leischik spurlos kostenlos auf dem
Podcast Player eures Vertrauens
Werbung Ende
aber erst einmal müssen wir erzählen wie
die beiden schließlich des Mordes
überführt wurden ja das ist an sich
schon mal eine krasse Story also zuerst
einmal ist da ihr Verhalten das bei
einigen Verdacht erweckt andererseits
der Umstand dass sie nur ziemlich kurz
trauern und danach auch beginnen das
Erbe zu verjubeln aber das ist ja noch
lange kein Mord Indiz vielleicht fühlen
Sie sich einfach nur befreit von ihren
viel zu strengen Eltern von denen sie
sich auch nie geliebt gefühlt haben und
dann ist da noch die Geschichte mit dem
Testament richtig die beiden haben
Freunden erzählt dass sie befürchten vom
Vater enterbt zu werden und das das ist
schon eher ein Motiv und es kommen noch
einige belastende Sachen dazu unter
anderem taucht ein Drehbuch auf dass
Erik zusammen mit einem Freund
geschrieben hat und das von einem jungen
Mann handelt der seine Eltern umbringt
um an ihr Erbe zu gelangen einen guten
Drehbuch über Mord das ist natürlich
kein Mord be ist aber so in der ganzen
Konstellation schon ein bisschen komisch
aber es ist halt nur ein weiteres Indiz
dass die Polizei dazu veranlasst die
Brüder nun doch etwas genauer unter die
Lupe zu nehmen und dann spricht Eric mit
seinem Freund Craig cinderelli über den
Mord er gesteht dir nicht direkt aber
offensichtlich muss da etwas aus ihm
heraus er sagt Sachen wie wenn wir
unsere Eltern ermordet hätten hätten wir
es so gemacht ja uns cinderelli der geht
zur Polizei die Polizei hält die beiden
Brüder inzwischen für die
Hauptverdächtigen und verkabelt sind ja
Rallye für ein weiteres Treffen mit Erik
bei diesem streitet er den Mord jedoch
vehement ab die Ermittlungen sind in
einer Sackgasse aber Eric hat noch
jemandem den Mord gestanden und zwar dem
Psychotherapeuten der Familie
geht zwar nicht zur Polizei weil er das
nicht darf da gilt nämlich die ärztliche
Schweigepflicht er hat jedoch zu der
Zeit eine Geliebte Julia Lanz Smith
seine Ehefrau die weiß nichts von der
Affäre die ganze Sache geht natürlich
furchtbar schief und Smith verlässt Dr
osian und dabei nimmt sie eine
Tonbandaufzeichnung eines Gesprächs
zwischen dem Therapeuten und Eric
millennis mit in dieser Tonband
Aufzeichnung da redet Eric über den Mord
Smith geht zur Polizei am 8 März 1990
wird Eric männendes schließlich
verhaftet sein Bruder stellt sich drei
Tage später und jetzt geht das Drama
eigentlich erst so richtig los über
diesen Prozess da gibt es eine Menge zu
erzählen
es wird eine Menge erzählt und eine
Menge geredet überall in den USA ein
Millionen Frühstückstischen und Kantinen
Kaffeeautomaten auf Barbecues und ein
vermutlich jedem Tresen zwischen Boston
und Los Angeles denn er wird live in
alle Wohnzimmer übertragen Kurt TV das
livegerichts-fernsehen erlebt mit dem
Fall der Minen des Brüder seinen großen
Durchbruch und das ist auch heute noch
im Internet zu finden
stundenlange Befragungen kreuzverhörige
Plädoyers alles vor den Augen der
Öffentlichkeit das wirkt irgendwie Pizza
auf mich obwohl auch ein bisschen
spannend also ich meine das kriegt man
ja sonst nicht mit
ein Mordprozess live im Fernsehen die
Kamera voll auf die Zeugen und die
Angeklagten gerichtet keine Mappe vor
dem Gesicht kein tief heruntergezogener
Hoodie nichts verpixelt einfach
draufgehalten Stunden Überstunden
ungekürzt als ob man wirklich mit im
Raum wäre ja wirklich seltsam dazu zu
schauen und die beiden Brüder zu sehen
von denen die Staatsanwaltschaft
behauptet sie hätten ihre Eltern eiskalt
und aus Habgier getötet
da sitzen einfach zwei junge Männer aber
gut wenn man einen Killer an seine
Nasenspitze erkennen würde dann wäre
Polizeiarbeit in Kinderspiel und alle
Krimis werden einfach nur
Kurzgeschichten du hast es gerade eben
schon gesagt vor Gericht behauptet die
Anklage die beiden hätten aus niederen
Motiven also aus Habgier gehandelt aber
was sagen denn die Angeklagten naja vor
allem gestehen sie ihre Eltern getötet
zu haben aber sie behaupten ist ein
Notwehr gewesen aber Moment mal die
Eltern die waren doch eindeutig wehrlos
als sie ermordet wurden ja das stimmt
aber nach Aussage der Brüder habe ihr
Vater gedroht sie zu töten und sein
Verhalten in den Stunden vor der Tat
hätte sie glauben lassen dass sie ihm
zuvorkommen müssten
dann kommen wir jetzt mal zum vielleicht
finstersten Teil dieser Geschichte Eric
und leise sagen aus dass ihr Vater sie
von frühester Kindheit an missbraucht
habe
immer und immer wieder bei leil dem
älteren endet der Missbrauch als er acht
Jahre alt war und sich der Vater auf den
jüngeren Eric konzentrierte
doch auch sein Leiden ging weiter seine
eigene Mutter Kitty missbrauchte ihn
ebenfalls
Eric wurde bis unmittelbar vor den
Morgen von seinem Vater brutal
vergewaltigt die Aussagen der beiden vor
Gericht sind unerträglich purer Horror
und der Vater habe ihn immer wieder
gedroht sie zu töten wenn Sie jemals
darüber sprechen sollten
nach einer ganz schlimmen
Auseinandersetzung mit ihrem Vater haben
die beiden beschlossen ihm zuvor zu
kommen sie kauften mit dem Führerschein
eines Bekannten in einem anderen
Bundesstaat sei Schrotflinten sie
kauften außerdem die Karten für den
Batman Film quasi als Alibi und dann
fuhren sie nach Hause dort wollten sie
noch mal mit ihrem Vater reden doch der
hatte sich zusammen mit der Mutter im
Arbeitszimmer eingeschlossen wo er auch
seine Waffen aufbewahrte paranoid und
den Todesangst holten sie daraufhin die
Waffen aus ihrem Wagen luden sie ging
zurück in das Haus und begann sofort zu
schießen die Staatsanwaltschaft zweifelt
diese Geschichte an sowohl den
Missbrauch als auch die Behauptung es
habe sich um eine Art Notwehr gehandelt
für sie ging es nur um Habsucht und
Heimtücke
eine Staatsanwältin geht so weit zu
behaupten Männer können nicht
vergewaltigt werden denn ihnen fehlt die
nötige Ausstattung um vergewaltigt zu
werden
also entschuldigung ich glaube da kann
ich nicht sagen ohne ausfallen zu werden
was ist das denn für ein Bullshit ja auf
jeden Fall was für eine absurde
unfassbar dämliche Aussage
die Staatsanwaltschaft versucht einfach
alles um die Aussage der Brüder
unglaubwürdig zu machen sie wollen sie
als eiskalte Killer verurteilt sehen
obwohl ein Cousin und eine Cousine vor
Gericht aussagen die beiden Brüder
hätten ihnen schon vor Jahren vom
Missbrauch durch den Vater erzählt
der Prozess platzt da sich beide Jurys
eine verleihe und eine für Eric nicht
einigen können es kommt zu einem zweiten
Prozess und diesmal bleiben die Kameras
draußen
es gibt aber trotzdem ein paar komische
Details der Richter begrenzt die
Aussagen zum sexuellen Missbrauch und
der Jury wird untersagt statt über Mord
über Totschlag abzustimmen
die Jury hat also nur die Wahl sie wegen
Mordes ersten Grades ins Gefängnis zu
schicken oder als unschuldig zu
entlassen
wie erklärt die beiden für schuldig die
Geschworenen sagen die
Missbrauchsvorwürfe hätten in ihren
Beratungen keine Rolle gespielt ein
Todesangst als Motiv glauben sie
ebenfalls nicht die Brüder hätten
getötet um an das Vermögen ihres Vaters
zu gelangen
da fiel mir wirklich die Worte so was
muss man doch berücksichtigen in so
einem Prozess also wenn es solche
Vorwürfe gibt aber okay hänge ich mich
jetzt nicht dran auf
weil und Eric millenndes entgegen der
Todesstrafe aber sie werden nie wieder
frei sein der Richter verurteilt sie zu
lebenslanger Haft ohne die Möglichkeit
einer Bewährung
habt ihr Angst Rache eine Mischung aus
allem
feststeht sie haben ihre Eltern getötet
aber ist es deshalb ein gerechtes Urteil
ja falls lebenslang ohne Aussicht auf
Bewährung überhaupt gerecht sein kann
aber das ist auch ein anderes Thema wenn
die missbrauchserzählung war es bleibt
es immer noch Mord das ist gar keine
Frage aber wenn das keine mildernden
Umstände sind dann weiß ich nicht was ob
diese Vorwürfe wahr sind das können wir
hier leider nicht klären und ehrlich
gesagt bin ich auch sehr froh darüber
dass wir hier nur von solchen Fällen
erzählen und nicht in der Haut derer
stecken die in solchen Situationen über
das wohl oder wer der Personen
entscheiden müssen
die beiden Brüder kommen in getrennte
Gefängnisse erst 2018 wird Lyle
mennendes in das Gefängnis seines
Bruders Eric verlegt und sie sehen sich
das erste Mal seit über 20 Jahren wieder
beide umarmen sich in Tränen aufgelöst
seither können Sie sich täglich sehen ah
und die beiden heiraten im Gefängnis
leil sogar zweimal seine erste Frau
verlässt ihn wegen Untreue ja wobei die
Untreue so aussieht dass lael auch eine
anderen Frau schreibt beiden Männern
werden eheliche Besucher wie es so schön
heißt also Sex verwehrt die Geschichte
der beiden schlägt bis heute hohe Wellen
wegen der besonderen Umstände der vielen
Ebenen und nicht zuletzt wegen des
Tatortes Beverly Hills also die Gegend
der Reichen und schön
unzählige Bücher und Filme handeln von
dem Fall oder wurden zumindest davon
inspiriert erst im Mai 2023 verkündete
Netflix den Titel einer neuen Serie
unter dem Titel Monsters the lion in
Eric manandis Story ja bleibt die Frage
wer in dieser Story das größte Monster
ist aber vielleicht sollten wir das Wort
überhaupt ganz vermeiden das waren keine
Monster das waren Menschen die uns tröst
gehandelt haben es wäre natürlich
einfacher zu sagen dass das Monster sind
aber ich glaube das ist dieser typische
Mechanismus um damit klar zu kommen dass
wir Menschen ich glaube jeder Mensch zu
sowas oder zu allem möglich ist oder in
der Lage ist
unterschied man dann gerne mit so
Begriffen wie Monster von sich weg wenn
man sich denkt das ist nicht menschlich
aber doch das gehört zu Menschen genauso
dazu
[Musik]
und damit sind wir am Ende der heutigen
Ausgabe angelangt wir freuen uns dass er
wieder mit dabei wart die Geschichte der
Minen des Brüder haben wir unter anderem
erzählt anhand eines sehr ausführlichen
Artikels der Los Angeles Times von 1990
mit dem Titel roseme nennen das gab
seinen Söhnen alles vielleicht auch ein
Mordmotiv
diese Artikel wurde noch vor bekannt
werden der Missbrauchsvorwürfe
veröffentlicht enthält aber ansonsten
sehr viele Details über das Leben der
Männer die Tat und die Ermittlungen
außerdem haben wir Artikel von ABC
news.com
warlography.com der Welt und einiger
anderen Quellen verwendet wir
verabschieden uns für heute und bedanken
uns bei Euch fürs zuhören und hoffe ihr
seid doch beim nächsten Mal wieder mit
dabei bis dahin euer Mirko und eure Toni